welcome to the program we begin with
breaking news coming out of jordan where
a court has sentenced two former
officials
for a plot against the monarchy former
royal court chief and finance minister
bassem awada was given 15 years hard
labor
and sharif hassan bin zayed a member of
the royal family
also got 15 years the verdict center on
an alleged plot against the kingdom
involving a former heir to the throne
prince hamza
he's king abdullah's half brother and a
former crown prince
regarding the first criminal basim
ibrahim the court has sentenced him to
temporary imprisonment for a period of
15 years for the first charge
and 15 years for the second charge only
one of these two rules applies to him
which is temporary work for 15 years
starting from the date of his arrest in
april with regard to the second criminal
sharif hassan bin zaid
the court has sentenced him to temporary
imprisonment for a period of 15 years
for the first charge and 15 years for
the second charge
he shall be subject to only one penalty
which is 15 years of temporary
imprisonment
is a professor of international
relations at qatar university and joins
me
from doha via zoom good to have you with
us on the programme
how significant was it to find those
behind this alleged coup
and bring them to justice
well it is very important for the
credibility of this regime in jordan
because the
accusation from the gecko was that there
was some kind of
even but then
they talked about the an attempt to
undermine stability in the region and
even decoded as sedition and actually
jordanians were
kind of upbeat to see bassam aldal in
particular
uh put in trial simply because he had
committed
or he's being accused of committing so
many um
economic crimes in jordan uh so i think
it's a kind of a relief
a relief for jordanian to see uh based
on
trial there will always be questions in
the international community about
whether this was a fair trial
considering the lawyers
for the accused have complained of a
lack of access to their clients
and potential torture to gain
confessions the trial was held behind
closed doors what are we to read into
this
well this is um a state court or
security court
uh so no one uh actually knows exactly
what happened behind the bars
uh we hear different stories from
different people uh according to
different
preferences uh but apparently uh
i i think that the court has been doing
the same thing
with other people as well in in the past
over the past 20 years we always hear
all of these complaints about the um you
know about what the court
or the interrogation itself uh in in
behind the bars what message really does
uh this send to the domestic audience in
jordan
considering there were accusations being
made that of a foreign plot to usurp the
monarchy
and connections to either saudi arabia
or even israel
well this is the problem here that you
know at the very beginning they talked
about this connection and then
the accusations um have nothing to do
with that
uh uh they only talk about baseball and
sharif
hassan brazil uh try in connection with
uh prince hamza trying to undermine
um stability in the country so there's
no
single accusation official acquisition
the court about
the foreign connections here and and
this is actually
leads to probably it weakened the
credibility of the whole case uh
as a whole uh many jordanians actually
uh suspect that
uh probably there was uh all the country
was afraid of
facing uh the real challenges that the
saudis and the israelis
i mean where does this leave prince
hamza who was sort of not involved in
this particular court case but he
accused the authorities at the time
of putting him under house arrest and
whose closest allies now have been found
guilty of sedition
amongst a raft of other charges
well if you uh if you hear the uh
acquisition list at the very beginning
and and also what passa aldola said in
the court uh this is what we read in the
press actually
uh it's obvious that they were trying to
convective in prince hamza so it's a
trial by absentees even for prince hamza
so uh i think this is the endgame they
want hamza to be out of the picture
uh there was so many many jordanians for
instance
one times it to be the the region but
now i think his chances are actually
slim
even next to zero uh so this is
here does this episode leave
king abdullah more exposed i mean the
floors and the holes in the
administration are open now for all to
see both
within the country and out of it and how
is the monarchy and the government going
to repair this damage
well it's a challenge now the king
actually
uh responded by forming a royal
committee
to modernize the you know to affect
kind of political reforms and probably
this is the only
thing or the only party he got in his
pocket
uh i would say the majority of jordan
even don't believe that hamza was
involved in anything like that
uh it's about the credibility as well
the trust gap between
the regime and jordan and the people is
actually widening
hassan barari professor of international
relations at qatar university
thanks very much for your insight sir
thank you thanks for having me